bonjour bonjour salut vous avez
rendez-vous pour le spa non j'ai un site
pour contrôler les comptes
[Rires]
ce matin c'est assez rare pour le
souligner en matière de sécurité
routière une réglementation moins
répressive sera mis en place à partir du
1er janvier 2024 désormais les
automobilistes ne perdront plus de
points en cas de petit excès de vitesse
petit excès de vitesse c'est s'il
dépasse la vitesse autorisée de 5 km/h
ouh vive l'intelligence vive le bon sens
tu enlèves le stress enfin il me semble
que ça va enlever du stress ce qui
dépasse à peine de 5 c'est pas les fous
du volant ça peut être n'importe qui
c'est moi c'est on a l'impression de
d'être des bons conducteurs des fois on
dépasse de 5 et on dit ma mince c'est la
première fois que je dépasse et là je
dis bah flûte quoi les automobilistes
fautifs péronnèrent une amende mais je
le répète sans conséquence pour leur
permis de conduire voilà une bonne
nouvelle les Français ne sont pas des
enfants et Gérald Darmanin qui est à
l'origine de cette mesure les traites
comme tel
[Applaudissements]
il y a un conducteur particulier un
grand champion de rallye Sébastien Loeb
qui a fait parler de lui en début de
semaine en déclarant on peut peut-être
le comprendre dans son cas particulier à
110 km/h au volant je suis plus
dangereux qu'à 180 km/h car j'ai
tendance à m'endormir ça peut être son
cas particulier me fait de le garder
pour lui bah c'est encore un message
mais c'est encore un message un petit
peu j'aime beaucoup Sébastien Loeb
j'aime beaucoup ce qu'il fait mais c'est
un message qui est quand même
qui particulier on peut voir donc une
photo de Michael Schumacher souriant et
en légende en jaune la première
interview événement mondial juste en
dessous en rouge ça sonne très vrai à
l'intérieur le magazine a enquêter on va
aller voir à l'intérieur justement
encore un portrait de Schumacher et
cette citation ma vie a totalement
changé ça donne envie d'en savoir plus
parce que depuis son accident de ski il
y a 10 ans effectivement pas de
nouvelles on sait juste qu'il a été dans
le coma pendant 6 mois et qu'il est dans
l'incapacité de communiquer
merci beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous et j'aimerais attirer votre
attention sur le petit encart à droite
de la photo Michael Schumacher donne une
interview pour la première fois depuis
son grave accident de ski mais est-ce
vraiment notre choumi qui parle
et donc c'est qui
bien sûr que non cette interview a été
complètement générée de A à Z par une
intelligence artificielle
Starship de SpaceX a parfaitement réussi
son décollage du centre d'essai de Boka
Chica au Texas mais son vol n'aura duré
que 3 minutes elle a ensuite explosée en
vol
[Applaudissements]
le patron de l'entreprise ne considère
pas cette explosion comme un échec le
fait que les fusée est réussi à décoller
représente à ses yeux déjà une immense
réussite cette fusée et destinée à terme
à des voyages vers la Lune et Mars dans
la nuit de Kiev cette nuit regardez
c'est énorme flash les Ukrainiens
pensaient que c'était un satellite la
NASA a démenti ni une bombe ni un
missile on a toujours pas l'explication
vous l'avez compris Rio affronte une
tempête tropicale d'une grande ampleur
jamais des finalistes n'ont été
confrontés à des conditions c'est
difficile c'est le pays est désagréable
certes mais elle va surtout
considérablement vous compliquer la
tâche pour le stop pour vous orienter
pour réussir à convaincre les gens ce
sera plus difficile que jamais les gens
les gens veulent l'électricité de quoi
créer un électrochoc chez le principal
fournisseur d'énergie en France qui ce
matin a rétabli la vérité avec humour
EDF fournisseur officiel des pharaons
depuis 2000 avant Jésus-Christ avec un
sous texte qu'on voit pas là mais qui se
moque gentiment non monsieur Gims quand
même pas mais on est certain que si
l'électricité avait existé autant des
pharaons il nous aurait sans doute
choisi un certain qui qu'ils affichent
déjà leur facture EDF vous voyez de
l'époque
c'est drôle
maître Gims lui-même en fait en fait
toute sa promo quand vous regardez sa
pochette d'album de son dernier titre
ben regardez il a mis l'a mis des
antennes
ils vous auraient choisi sauf sans doute
en cas de conflit social parce que
j'ajoute une info info c'est à vous
savez combien les grèves ont coûté à EDF
depuis le début du mouvement
d'euros c'est à dire à peu près le prix
d'une pyramide parce que vous connaissez
le premier
oui
vous avez des
pancakes
qui a raison c'est chaussettes et
claquettes ça c'est quand même pas
possible Christophe Willem mais c'est
pas possible qu'est-ce qui vous arrive
aujourd'hui le gouverneur de Floride
rentre de Santis et ses députés veulent
aller encore plus loin avec les médecins
personnels soignants et assurance
pourrait refuser des soins à certaines
personnes
cette loi permettra à tous les
personnels de santé de refuser tout
service de soins qui violeraient leur
conscience même si le projet de loi ne
fait pas mention explicite de
l'homosexualité les associations LGBT
s’estiment clairement visées et dénonce
une dérive dangereuse
[Musique]
la positive
mais par exemple si je dis que mon
partenaire est un homme le médecin
pourrait me dire je refuse de vous
prescrire des médicaments comme ceux de
prévention contre le sida parce que ça
me pose un problème moral de soigner des
gens comme vous et cela alors que pour
moi les soignants font ce métier pour
aider les autres et près de serment
experts indépendants qui ont lu en
détail le projet de loi il s'agit bien
de discrimination
[Musique]
on a gagné